[Music]
hello and welcome to expectatures energy
summit kindly sponsored by
national grid we're meeting today in
um pretty uncertain times we're um
we're speaking we're coming to you
streaming to your homes and your offices
our guests
are all remote the uk has just gone
through
the sharpest recession in living memory
and it might be about to enter
another one with a new lockdown so
everything is
up in the air but even if 2020 had not
thrown us this giant cobit curveball
we would still today be discussing the
subjects we're discussing right now
and the discussion which the prime
minister has put at the center of his
post-covet recovery plan
which is how to proceed with the green
agenda and the 2050
net zero there are several questions
that
might have been answered had the cop 26
climate change summit in glasgow
gone ahead and it's been delayed for
understandable reasons and so has the
government's
energy policy but we're going to have
quasi-courting the energy minister
give a keynote address later on today to
talk us through
some of these issues the agenda now
and we're going to be discussing
leveling up and how far
the green agenda fits with leveling up
and of course leveling up is now a
question of reconstruction
how do we rebuild the economy and how
many of lessons
that we've learned in the last few
months will help towards that aim
many of us are been living and working
in ways we would never have thought
were plausible a few months ago and i
imagine many of you watching this now
will basically have adopted
new working mechanisms during the
lockdown but kept them throughout the
summer because they were working
to a surprising extent for a lot of
companies to what extent will these new
habits we've learned help
accelerate the 2050 agenda and to what
extent might it happen under his own
steam
not needing government policy the energy
revolution of the last few months has
also continued to pace we've seen
incredible fluctuations in the oil
market we've seen the price of oil
and drop below zero dollars a barrel at
one point
meanwhile we've seen the price of wind
power dropped to levels
we never would have thought possible
only a few
years ago we've also seen britain
emerge as one of the world leaders in
wind power with something like a third
of all the world's offshore
wind farms so now that we are creating
a new industry is this something that
again which the government
needs to stoke or is it something which
has now got enough momentum
to continue on its own we have got
um several panels today at 9 50 we're
going to have
quasi-quartin giving us that keynote at
10 30 we're going to be discussing
how the green agenda merges with
leveling up agenda which
with lord curse lake who's chair of the
uk 2017 commission
and ben hutchin who's mayor of mt's
valley
and lastly at 11 20 we're going to be
asking tough questions about
whether green energy really does have
the potential to meet the demands
of our energy intensive society we're
going to be lord
joined by lord devin who's chairman of
the climate change committee
and lady verma who's former minister of
energy and climate change along with
other experts in the field
but first i'm delighted to hand over to
nicolas shaw
executive director of national grid and
sponsor of today's summit
who will help set the scene for this
today's discussion over to you nicola
thanks fraser and thank you everyone for
joining us today
as fraser said we're all in our homes or
old not likely in our homes and
it's a very different world from the one
i think we might have expected a year or
so ago
and but really nice that you've joined
us so thank you and i think it would be
great to have the conversation today
to make sure that the energy sector does
play its real
part in supporting the recovery um
we've got a massively mixed economy we
always have
and the discussion that fraser just went
through i think illustrated that very
well
the importance of both the public sector
and the private sector pulling together
in this partnership
and for a future that works for everyone
is absolutely key
the national grid is at the backbone of
the energy system
of the uk we have we recognize a really
important role in enabling this green
recovery
we think that means that we need to
continue to invest in solutions for
decarbonization um
both for the sector specifically the
energy sector but also more widely in
society
in particular in transport and in heat
we think those things are
the leading areas that we need to focus
on
as we decarbonize we also know that
people are on board with that mission
there's a real support for the net zero
agenda
across the uh country and keeping that
with us
and as we know that climate change is
this defining feature for the generation
we must think about the decisions we're
taking now and how they're going to
influence the future of the planet
um otherwise i think it could become
even more significant and hence
key this decade is really key so what is
it this
decade that we can do well we can do an
enormous amount in terms of
magnifying that wind that fraser had
already talked about
so maybe up to four times as much wind
by 2030 as
we're using today to create low carbon
electricity
um we're going to start installing low
heat carbon heating systems in new homes
and in existing homes probably up to
about 3 million homes with low carbon
heating by the end of the decade
we will be developing carbon capture and
storage systems
and developing hydrogen networks and we
will be installing
about 60 000 charging points so we can
power 11 million electric vehicles
uk's leadership in the sector has been
enormous
and we talked about our international
leadership both in funding
and transforming the lower carbon energy
system
as we continue through the pandemic and
the recession i think
it's an opportunity for us to lead and
continue to show
that we can do that across the country
not leaving anyone behind
the fairness of this transition is
something that has come out to us
time and time again in the analysis
we've done of what
consumers want and what voters want it's
important for all of us
so i think there are real opportunities
and i'm hoping that this conference will
unpack some of that talk about what it
would mean locally what it would mean
nationally
what it means for business and what it
means from
government i think all of those are
important
um things we can do now accelerating and
really leveraging on the work on
electric vehicles
it's evident that that change is coming
in the next few years
really building on uh the zero carbon
industrial clusters that are being
developed
and the humber and t side is one and i
know you'll talk about that later
economic opportunities from offshore
wind and i said that there'll be growth
of about four times in the next decade
but by 2050 that's about 75 gigawatts of
wind about a seven
or eight times growth from where we are
now
and then there will be more
interconnectors more interconnectors
between us and europe
bringing further clean energy into the
country and making sure it's easier to
balance the system
at all times which is vital for security
of supply
and then i think we'll see lots of
change in the area of hydrogen
there are lots of schemes and
development projects underway at the
moment
and those will really come to fruition
over this next 10 years
and national grid is the heart of each
of those things i
look forward to talking to you further
seeing what government's going to do to
unleash
back to you now to get the discussion
underway thank you again for hosting
this
important set of discussions thank you
nichola now let's move swiftly on to our
first
panel this morning which will look at
how and indeed
whether the uk's climate ambitions are
compatible with our economic recovery
from covet now back in the spring the uk
experienced its sharpest economic
contraction for 300
years hopes for a v-shaped recovery
which were being articulated by the andy
holden the chief economist of the bank
of england only a few weeks ago
are now waning pretty fast so we've had
circuit breakers fire breakers and
lockdowns forcing businesses to close
their doors again
and people are heading back home the
latest
shape of economic recovery we saw
yesterday wasn't a v
it was a w forcing some very hard
questions about
how we're going to pay for this and how
government needs to prioritize itself
now we know that the claim uk climate
change committee has
calculated that this will cost about one
percent of uk gdp that's between 20
and 40 billion pounds a year potentially
making it one of the most expensive
promises the government is making in the
posts
covid's um world so is it still
affordable to what extent have the
changes we've seen in society this
stunning economic contraction
shown that might not be as expensive as
people had originally thought
or is this going to be something the
government will look back on
in later years as a rather lavish
promise
made in the days where they could afford
more expensive promises than they're
going to be able to keep
in the post-m covered world the
government's due to
unveil plans for a new state-backed
green bank that will finance
the climate ambitions and the chancellor
has unveiled something like
2 billion pound grant scheme to insulate
homes that will
provide those green jobs and improve
energy efficiency
so is economic growth compatible with
sustainable
development i'm delighted to be joined
in the next panel by
bim nephilim who's chair of the all
party group of renewable and sustainable
energy
by john soven who's the executive
director of greenpeace
by paulie billington director of uk 100
and by graham cooper who's project
director of national grid
we're all going to make some opening
remarks we're going to open it up then
for a general discussion
but we'll also be taking questions from
you so please do
send them using the magical powers of
zoom communications
and so let's start so if i can ask you
ben who's it i see your donor spectator
offices there
in westminster um please take it away
it's a pleasure to be here thank you
very much for having me
quite simply i believe that economic
recovery is
is compatible with with a sustainable
future
and there are two main reasons for that
the first
is we don't really have a choice because
climate change
is coming upon us uh and
this government uh over the last ten
years has has done
broadly speaking the right things but
we're gonna have to continue doing that
and intensify that
what does that look like in terms of
sustainability though what are the
actions we actually need to take
i'd look at two principal areas energy
transformation and the financing of it
in relation to energy
transformation we are going to have to
significantly upgrade and increase the
amount of investment that goes into
renewable energy
nuclear energy things like electric cars
that that mature from from
national grid mentioned but those things
are not just policy things they're not
just statements they will require
cash now cash can come from one of two
sources
the first is the private sector the
other is the public sector the private
sector
we need to make the regulatory changes
in order to get more private sector
funds in to do that
but at the same time we are going to
have to increase our public sector
spending in that
and not be shy of that and use that as a
lever
to help leveling up in big parts of this
country
in particular i think of nuclear energy
where there where nuclear energy is
um where it tends to be situated places
like cumbria
the coastal areas um where there's a big
need for leveling up
renewable energy which frankly is is
almost all parts of the country and
indeed offshore
but it's not just economic recovery in
terms of leveling up
it's also how do we use our strengths in
the services sector financial services
sector
to help finance that bring that private
sector funding in
and to help expand and export those
technologies
to other parts of the world and so i can
see that sort of uniting between
uh re-rewiring our industrial heartlands
with using our server sector strength
and those two things combined
i think look like a good economic
recovery to me thanks very much
now i'd like to pass over to john
sullivan the executive director of
greenpeace
and thank you and i just wanted to pick
up actually uh a couple of points
made by bim and fraser in your
introduction i mean i think first of all
as you're right in terms the world has
changed dramatically
as a result of kobe but it's also been
changed
changing dramatically if you look over
the last
uh decade since the 2008 financial
crisis because
if you look then when we built back
after that financial crisis
a lot of it was in high polluting
industries and what happened while co2
emissions
dramatically went up after that
financial crisis
uh was over but but when you look at for
example the smith school of oxford
university who did a study on all the
packages that were done after the
financial crisis they found that the
green packages
were much more economically viable in
terms of providing
jobs and recovery and so on so there
were lessons to be learned from that
but i think also if you fast forward
just over a decade you also find that
renewable energy the price of renewable
energy in the last decade has collapsed
as you rightly said in terms of
offshore wind onshore wind solar the
price of batteries has dropped
90 percent in the last 10 years
oil companies share prices have
collapsed more than 50 percent
renewable energy companies now in terms
of
market capitalization are now ahead of
some of the biggest oil companies in the
world so
the whole landscape is so dramatically
different today than 10 years ago
and i think that that gives us huge
cause for optimism when you
look at going forward here in terms of
fiscal stimulus or government support
because it's it's not really money
particularly we're talking about here
what we're really talking about here is
proper government
regulation and policies that will
provide a framework for private
investors
to actually invest and they just need
certainty
that's probably the most important thing
that is required because
for example the offshore wind industry
will require 50 billion pounds worth of
investment over the coming decade
so getting the right regulatory
environment for the offshore wind
industry is really critical
and that's a government issue it's not
money
they need to sort out things like the
grid infrastructure like the issues
around environmental protections
um issues around you know crown estate
dealing with the
mod and the civil aviation authority
over radar these are all
challenges which the government needs to
sort out and if they don't then there
won't be
a successful offshore wind industry they
will not meet their 40 gigawatt target
but it's not money and i think that the
same thing
when you look at for example electric
vehicles we just need the government to
announce
that there will be a phase out date for
the internal combustion engine
by 2030 and the price of electric
vehicles
is dropping dramatically as the price of
batteries drops dramatically
and i would say the same with energy
efficiency the government has had
lots of programs on energy efficiency
and the chancellor
we welcomed announced the new package in
terms of fiscal stimulus for
energy efficiency but it was quite
short-term
and the government really needs to think
long-term and that's really the last
point i wanted to make
we've got six parliaments for 2050.
they need a plan working back over those
six parliaments there is cross-party
support for this there's broad support
out there in the country but they need a
plan working back from
that and in particular the next decade
is
absolutely critical in terms of
actually trying as far as we can to half
global emissions by 2030
if we want to keep to within a two
degree or less than two degree rise in
global average temperatures
so what we do in the coming decade is so
important and that's obviously why
getting countries globally to agree to
much more ambitious plans
ahead of the glasgow summit uh is really
critical and
that i think is also showing quite
positive signs in terms of the uk
government
was the first economy to announce that
2015 net zero
now followed by china 2016 south korea
2050 japan 2050
if biden wins tomorrow he'll announce
2050.
you know this is now a much more
collective
global effort by major powers which we
haven't seen
happen in the last four or five years
john thanks very much indeed and now i'd
like to pass over to
graham cooper who's project director of
national grid
hi thank you fraser and good morning
everyone yeah
i i won't repeat the the great message
of bill and john
um i guess the important thing from a
national grid perspective is
we've talked about the growth
opportunity in offshore wind
we've talked about the downstream
decarbonisation of transport so
cars and decarbonization of heat
national grid is really the critical
element that joins the two together
so ultimately where that clean energy is
generated and
how it gets to where it needs to be
consumed is critical to
to success you need to look at the whole
system
so from national grid's perspective um
you know the grid
is happy and able to cope with this
transition
uh as long as we are in a position where
we are able to
have strategic investments ahead of need
you know coming back to the plan that
you know having a plan that john
articulated um
the grid has generally been regulated in
a way to react
to a mature market what we're seeing
here is almost creation of new markets
so
decarbonization transport to
carbonization of heat large scale
offshore wind
we've coped with the the changes so far
and we will cope with the changes going
forward
but having a regulation that regulates
for net
zero rather than regulate for the short
term will actually give that confidence
that john spoke about to allow the
market
and to allow all the investment that's
needed
the i guess the other linking to this is
if you read the committee on climate
change you know reports on net zero
we're gonna need four times the amount
of renewables that we have today
and that is going to need to facilitate
a grid that's twice as big as we have
today
and that drives a tremendous amount of
jobs so our own analysis
uh seems to to indicate that we're gonna
need roughly 400 000
jobs in the net zero economy between now
and 2050.
i'd also point out that in your
classical business model and
your business model and business studies
how do you recover from a recession
one of the best things you can do in a
recession is invest in the
infrastructure
yes it is a cost now but we will reap
the benefits for
very very many years the infrastructure
that national grid deploys today
will be operational in net zero our kit
lasts broadly 40 years
and therefore having the right stimulus
to get the right energy networks in the
right place
at the right time ahead of need and to
be future proof
has to actually be the foundation stone
of
of the green recovery and allowing us to
be on a trajectory to net zero
so i'll stop at that point and hand back
to you fraser
thanks very much great now i'd like to
bring in polly billington who's director
of uk
100. uh thanks very much fraser and um
it's lovely to be on a panel where there
is
arguably so much violent agreement um uk
100 is a network of local leaders
committed to 100 clean energy by 2050
and in fact we're upping our ambition
to upping our commitment uh collectively
as a group
because so many of our members have
already made more ambitious commitments
than that over the past couple of years
because to answer briefly the question
that has been posed
can we have an economic recovery and is
it compatible with
um our net zero ambitions we can't do it
without it
this is ultimately an opportunity to
learn the mistakes of
the past that john soven pointed out
that actually you can have
more labor intensive and more job
creation in green industries
than you can in some of the more more
polluting ones and that that's a lesson
from the past we know that's
the case now and also it goes to issues
of place
because um i um it's great to talk about
the offshore wind story and that
offshore wind story is one of actually
political consensus over more than 10
years that vision
was first outlined before 2010 it was
broadly implemented between 2010 and
2015
and as an and we're now reaping the
benefits so that 47
of our electricity was uh renewable on
the grid
um in the first quarter of 2020. now
when we were talking about that kind of
thing before 2010
many people thought it would be
impossible and that we were throwing
good money after bad
however that's great but you cannot
decarbonize the whole community
the whole whole of the country by simply
doing it all
offshore it actually has to happen in
places and that goes to
not only graham's point about the
importance of decarbonizing heat and
transport because those things happen in
places
it also goes to an economic desire to be
able to rebalance our economy across the
country
now our local leaders know that they
know that there is an opportunity for
jobs
and it was interesting graham mentioned
the idea of maybe 500 000 jobs
in order to be able to meet net zero
we've identified 500
000 jobs just to do the retrofit green
van
work that needs to be done in the next
10 years or so
um with our within our analysis that we
did with lse grantham institute
so the opportunity to be able to turn
what the government has done initially
with something like the green homes
grant into a long-term
transformation of the fabric of our
country not only the
the fabric of our country in the the
homes and the buildings that we live but
also the economic regeneration that will
create is really exciting
and that's just the retrofit bit if you
think about the amount of people who
are in the construction industry who are
on furlough who could be
retrained and re-skilled and redirected
towards that kind of work
it could be transformative it's not
straightforward but it is an indication
of what needs to happen
and of course those jobs don't get
concentrated in places where there
already is
or is traditionally a certain amount of
wealth it has to happen everywhere
but one other point on the issue of
place which i think is important
is that we um john mentioned the issue
of the phase out
of electric vehicles we know one of the
greatest anxieties that people have
um is not only about the price of
electric vehicles but whether they're
going to be able to charge them
now you can you can send a strong
regulatory message to the market by
phasing out the vehicles
and that's very much supported by our
members but also what they want to see
is a seamless ev infrastructure
again what does that require it requires
jobs and it requires jobs
everywhere one more point on the issue
to do with capacity
um because a lot of people will say oh
the grid's not big enough it can't cope
with it and
graham is right to talk about the fact
that it needs to be renewed and it's one
of the asks of our task force
our resilient recovery task force which
said if there's going to be a
comprehensive
spending review ever hopefully when
there is one one of the key things we
need to do
is to re invest in renewing the grid
in order to be able to have it to be a
decentralized and decarbonized one
now in 2026 the national grid will
celebrate a hundred years of existence
it was uh it was an opportunity it was
something that was uh introduced in a
period of recession under a conservative
prime minister
at a time when people really didn't know
whether those kind of things could
happen and yet somebody had
the guts to do something really big and
say that electricity was something that
everyone should
have access to and it grew out of local
electricity companies we don't know
really
or nobody's explained a proper vision of
what a future national grid should look
like
that would be able to meet the needs and
of the future of this country
and graham's totally right and being
able to invest in a head of need is
absolutely what our members want
because without it they won't be able to
transform their com their
their communities in the way that
they've committed to so when we think
about capacity and we worry about our
energy attentive industries and
decarbonizing them
think also of those de-industrialized
places those places are desperate for
leveling up
and where there is actually capacity on
the grid and we could be doing something
really transformative
about our industries and particularly
about decarbonizing
in those places thank you polly
well um you you pointed out those
violent
agreements on this panels let's try to
change that
a little bit i was quite taking john
sullivan by your point
that what the industry needs now isn't
so much money it's
certainty now this is quite a departure
typically people
characterize the green debate as being
okay let's move to a green future but by
the way
these things aren't economically
sustainable so it needs masses of
subsidy from the government
now this calculation changes when we see
the the recent auctions for green energy
coming in at way less than for example
the hinckley point
strike price that was agreed under
george osborne
and you talk about the way that and the
batteries have fallen by
90 percent in in in cost as well
so the economics of this seem to be um
coming on pretty nicely without
government subsidy so can you say a bit
more
about regulation because i'd like to
contrast this with
polly because you mentioned poly
investment ahead of need
i'm assuming the investment you're
referring to is investment from from the
government but john first can you just
say a little bit more about your point
about how certainty is more important at
the moment than subsidy
yes well i suppose yeah you don't often
get to
uh um you know to have such a win-win
situation
uh i suppose but but i think that the
the key thing here is and i think poorly
alluded to this is that if you go back
uh not that many years actually five or
ten years
the price of offshore wind was the most
expensive power
uh in the uk and actually there was
fierce criticism
uh the amount of money the government
was subsidizing offshore when
uh at and but of course today
you could actually get into a situation
well it's definitely subsidy free i
would say
um and and so i think that we're seeing
this across the board with with many
different
uh technologies and this is partly
because of the role
of china uh because they've mass
produced
many things uh and even become a world
leader in many of these areas whether
it's
ev or or electric vehicles or batteries
or
various different kinds of renewable
energy particular solar panels so i mean
they have mass-produced
the technology that has very often been
developed in the west
but they've commercialized it on a
massive and global scale and driven the
cost down
so i think that the question now is is
this regulatory
framework in which you want to attract
private
investors and i think we have in general
reached a relatively
sweet spot when it comes to this and i
agree there is a check
chicken and egg situation like if you
don't have charging points people
won't buy electric vehicles so the
charging infrastructure has to go in
and then you said the private investors
say well i'm not paying for a charging
infrastructure going
if nobody's going to buy electric
vehicles but if the government then says
well actually
we're going to phase out electric
vehicles and actually we're going to ban
them from 2030 onwards
well private investors then know that
the take-up of electric vehicles
is going to be i think what
was the national grid was 11 million
electric vehicles by 2030.
so there is a a massive market here
which the government is almost
guaranteeing
by regulation uh not by money
and i think that this applies to a whole
suite of things where
the right framework and the right
regulation would actually go a long way
and i say this just one key example is
because i think the point polly was
making about this was really critical in
terms of energy efficiency
we have 26 million homes here which need
upgrading in terms of energy efficiency
and many other buildings besides
the the chancellor announced an energy
efficiency program
in the budget but to begin with it was
only to last six
months and i think that that's my point
it takes more than six months to build a
supply chain
skill and retrain people you know set up
an apprenticeship program and so on and
so forth if they looked at this
in terms of what do we want to do
between now and 2030
here's the regulatory framework we're
going to guarantee this is going to
happen
it would have cross-party support
because a lot of people say oh well you
might have a new parliament in
in in four years time but the labour
party and all the other parties support
action on climate change to the same or
a higher degree
so this so there could be a huge degree
of
uh political certainty and regulatory
certainty which i think would then
help private investment uh deliver what
needs to be done
and thanks john and bim can i take you
um
in here it's um quite interesting here
that
make sure everybody says they want
certainty but i'm wondering if you think
in the current circumstances when
you know certainty seems to be the last
thing that anybody is able to
come up with but can you i'm wondering
how you see
the recent upheavals what we've been
through as a country in the last
six to eight months what way do you
think it's it's changed the calculations
uh do you think it's harder for
government now to offer certainty over
the rest of his decade
or do you think that what we've seen in
the last few months has underlined the
need
for change i think that
there will be a temptation amongst some
in government
to see this as look this is all a bit
too difficult at the moment
you know god make me good but not yet
we've just got to get through the next
you know the next few months or year or
so i think that so so you're right that
some people may think that i actually
think this is when we need to do
precisely
the opposite be bolder um
what what does that look like i think
that looks like
in political terms and you know i
suppose i should bring the politics to
this
you know we have a lot of areas that are
voting conservative for the first time
that are a big number of their jobs are
in carbon intensive industries
now if we postpone the action that
i think everybody has agreed that that
we want to take that makes it
harder in the medium term for us to deal
with that those problems not easier
so i think that we've actually if we you
know if we if we want to try and hold
these areas for a sustained period of
time we're gonna have to act now
uh in order to deal with that so i think
that that's something we need to do
and secondly and this is something that
you know i keep thinking you know if the
chancellor was here or one of his teams
here what would they be saying and
they'd probably be screaming
debt and taxes at the moment and they'd
be saying
you're talking about spending all this
money how are we going to pay for it
and i think we need to start having a
serious conversation about
increasing taxes and it's very odd for
me as a conservative and a fiscal
conservative to talk about increasing
taxes
increasing taxes on carbon
intensive damaging activities
luring them on you know good things so
to speak in climate terms
so it's help first of all in the short
term raise revenue
then in the second term to help
accelerate the changes that we need to
have
and accelerate it without huge public
subsidy but through
the private sector reallocating its
capital
and indeed people reallocating their
labor to where the jobs are
so that's in economic terms what i think
we need to do we need to start having
those tough conversations around tax
input thanks for that bib so and graham
cooper can i bring you in here you came
up with a phrase that polly also used
strategic investment ahead of need
um i'm i probably should know what that
means but i don't can you
just say a little bit more about about
what you're referring to it sounds like
a euphemism
yeah yeah so no i'll try to try and make
it really really simple so
um before i joined national grid i i was
a wind farmer so i worked for a business
that developed half a billion pounds of
the wind
so what you ended up having to do as a
wind farmer is
start to develop your wind farm apply
for a grid connection and you wait a
long time for the grid
to get to you if you're looking at a
world where
time now is currently our biggest enemy
actually
putting the great grid infrastructure in
the right locations
so that you're not waiting for the grid
and and therefore investment ahead of
need
is the right thing to do are you let's
use a really nice simple example
so we talked about um briefly uh the the
transition
to um decarbonizing transport
so the challenge around decarbonizing
transport is
actually one of confidence what you need
is the confidence that your first and
only car can be electric
that you can drive further than the
range of the car and that wherever you
go
you will find that charging is not a
barrier to your journey
so that needs some you know big
government sort of uh strategy that says
confidence is the critical one here
have evenly spaced charging across the
motorway network which is what the
office of low mission vehicles is is
working up now
um deploy the grid infrastructure
and then the future cars vans trucks
buses and coaches that are coming
between
you know now and 2035 and then the
charge point infrastructure can
plug into that in a scalable way so you
do it right
do it once and that needs that that
infrastructure deployment
first to de-risk that market to allow
those charge points to go in
in time so it's actually one of
confidence so if you see the right
infrastructure being in the right place
then you can then make
you know private enterprise can make
plans to then
act on that the other thing i think
we've also found is
um being a price regulated monopoly
national grid is obviously
rightly scrutinized by our regulator so
we are
you know measured about delivering the
perfect um and we're penalized if we
don't deliver the perfect
the challenge we've got in the world
we're moving into is the market is
moving very very quickly
into carbonizing heat and transport and
growth in offshore wind
so what we actually need to do is not
wait for the perfect
what we need to do is get going now on
the good
you know the least regrets rather than
trying to dial out the perfect
and so that needs that forward vision um
and forward regulation and up until now
we've had a regulator's done a really
really good job of regulating for today
but actually what we need is regulation
to regulate for net zero
because then you might make different
longer term
value judgments thanks graeme i'm now
going to
go to a question from one of our viewers
gordon taylor
and puts this question to you polly if
the future envisaged
by the panelists comes to pass how much
will the average
person's energy bills increase by well
that
sort of goes to the to what graham said
it sort of it really does depend on the
regulator
and it goes to bim's point about where
taxes fall at the moment
most of the decarbonization burden
actually goes on your electricity bill
so you're paying more for your cleaner
electricity
your your cleaner power you don't have
that the same
level of burden on your gas bill now 70
percent of people
um who are in fuel poverty rely on gas
for to heat their homes
so if i was to say yes we must shift the
the burden of um
of carbon from electricity to gas we'd
create
lots more people um in fuel poverty
without creating
which would which wouldn't be desirable
but we do have to think about
why what the price of electricity is
higher
even though it's now cleaner than
uh than gas and if we're talking about
decarbonizing heat we're going to have
to be able to
reposition those things to encourage and
incentivize people
to use cleaner heat than we currently do
on gas
so i don't have a number um that number
and when there are those numbers modeled
they change quite a lot and it really
does depend
on what the regulator decides what's
been problematic
as it goes to graham's point is that off
gem is always
focused on the price now rather than the
price in the future
and ultimately while doing that is
setting up problems for the prices for
the future and the cost for the future
because if you only worry about the
price now you actually
make it more expensive in the future and
there are lots of low regrets options
that could be incentivized in the next
10 years and need to be if we're going
to meet the science
and thanks paul yeah and phrase phrases
just
on that point this is so critically
important i mean graham could speak with
much more
expertise than than me on this but even
if you take the
offshore wind industry which is trumped
as a huge success the grid connections
coming onshore from offshore wind farms
are very expensive
because it's not thought about
strategically and it's not thought about
in terms of the future system where you
need less connections
it will be far cheaper to think about
this in a strategic sense
and people's bills would be reduced as a
result of that
and this is a real failure of offshore
and the government actually
not to provide a proper regulatory
regime
for the grid and as as being said this
is really important for all other areas
this is this is this infrastructure we
need to get right and at the moment it's
not
so i'd like to try to come in on there
because one thing that's very very
useful actually at the point uh
john is i think uh certainly bays
get this they've just formed a working
group
to actually look at coordinated grid you
know
shared infrastructure in the sea um and
that's a really good thing to do
i guess the thing from my perspective is
that power also needs to land
onshore and so it the offshore
coordination needs to consider
everything in the round so not just the
offshore wind farm interconnection
boot straps how it arrives on the beach
but also how it's then moved around the
country
my concern from that perspective is is
that's going to take some time
i come back to my point that there are
you know planning applications need to
go in now
for infrastructure that's going to be
delivered in 2028
and any delay now in deciding what the
perfect may be
pushes that timeline further and further
towards 2030
so i think there's a there's an
interesting trade off here
government needs to look at those
coordinations to to make better
decisions but we can't try and wait to
engineer the perfect to be getting on
with what's just good now
and it's the management of that
transition is actually where there's
some real opportunity
to to to understand the value of time
and
the the doing the right things in the
right order but i think there is a
recognition we just need to move faster
would be my
my view sure mr graham i have to say
it's
it's quite cheery hearing you talk about
a choice between the perfect and the
good in times like these where either
seems
quite a long way off but the next
question from susan carey and it's to
you ben and what's happened to the
nuclear energy that the conservatives
used to be so keen on
how will the rule will that play in
getting to
net zero or is it the case that
developments and renewables especially
the price of wind power
i've now moved on so much that we can
now
see the hinckley points deal as the
decisions of yesteryear that simply
didn't envisage
how prices would collapse so much in
renewable energy
and how reliable renewable energy would
become
it's a good question i think it was a
decision of yesteryear but i also think
it needs to be as
a decision of today and one of tomorrow
and i strongly support
the government reinvesting in nuclear
power i think it's absolutely critical
there needs to be a good mix of energy
we've talked about onshore and offshore
wind
that's i think everybody agrees we need
that and yes the
the cost of it has has dropped
significantly but
one of the reasons why the cost of
nuclear has historically
been a bit high is because of the
constant regulatory changes
and we need to think of a new financing
model for nuclear
so yes we need to get the cost of
nuclear down but i don't see
in the next 10 15 years with the amount
of sort of fossil fuel energy coming
off stream i don't see us
us really being able to generate the
amount of energy that we need
without at least one but possibly even
two or three
nuclear power stations coming on stream
and i strongly support it
from just simply generating enough
energy when i have this debate with
people in the industry some people don't
like the term base load energy
but i think it is an important concept
to make sure that
we do just structurally increase that
reliable constant level of energy
that nuclear can provide so i i strongly
support it and i think
on the conservative benches there's a
there's preponderance of support
of it and i think we need to do it as
make that decision as soon as possible
john sullivan what's your take on on
nuclear energy do you have reservations
well no i'm always just surprised at the
conservative government supporting the
french and chinese governments because
you have to remember nuclear power
stations are only built by the state
and in in in the uk sense they're only
built by the chinese state and the
chinese communist party
and the french state that own edf and
they can only be built with government
support government subsidy
uh government ownership which is what
the uk government's discussing at the
moment so
i do find this a bit weird uh frankly uh
their love of um
a technology that is so state-controlled
and has huge security implications
i also think the world's changing look
offshore wind is a bit like base load
power
um the wind out at sea blows pretty much
fairly constantly all the time and of
course when you get to
floating offshore winds uh wind power
stations which will be further out
you'll get even
even more wind and then you've also got
hydrogen and you've got green hydrogen
you've got
actually a storage mechanism coming
along
with the wizard again the drop in the
price of electrolyzers and so on
so i think that you can actually design
a smart energy system around
energy efficiency solar wind geothermal
other renewable technologies
linked with interconnectors going into
europe a future that's
also going to be hydrogen is also going
to be critically important so i think
it's possible to envisage
a different kind of a future and then of
course you've also got
you know other people would say well we
need carbon capture and storage
i don't think you need all i don't think
you need nuclear carbon capture storage
and renewable energy and green hydrogen
and all the other things that go with it
i think some choices
need to be made and nuclear is probably
the most expensive
of all of them well john thanks very
much
and now that's it for our first m's
panel of the morning for our next one
we've got quizzy cortang the energy
minister
giving us his keynote speech now and i i
in my
mind i like to think of us all in being
a whole and i would ask you to put your
hands together to thank
our panels so um let's do it virtually
ben graham john and paulie
thank you very much for this fascinating
discussion and
to those of you watching the home let's
um let's go to quasi quarten
via the spectator tv website thanks very
much